cs:go has one of the most diverse and
talented group of casters in all of
these sports adding their talents to
make great games even better so whether
they're hype or hilarious
here are our picks for the top 10 best
caster calls in csgo Cooter's clutch
against vex gaming is incredibly tense
and DDK made sure everyone in the
audience felt every second of the defuse
this pit position is so hard to deal
with cuchinis the son of a lifetime to
pick off brawl and he's going even for
the jumps this is so incredibly small
from Roland Kucha trying to get that
angle waiting patiently but he can't
pick it up but it's gonna be time is
that time great casting and a great
moment to kick off our list
sometimes pure enthusiasm can make a
great play even better seriously nobody
loves csgo quite as much as the VAM and
it shows in our pick for number 9 blend
blend blend blend zip 5 seconds 5
seconds dude 5 seconds old too
what just happened in here oh my
goodness
economy and csgo can be confusing to
explain in the heat of the moment
luckily James Bardolph has you covered
at number eight with a simple and
hilarious metaphor that equates s case
full by to a burger with all the
trimmings we trust our buyouts and it's
not a lot teams that do that they want
the mayonnaise in their burgers and the
mustards and all the trimmings they
don't just one the but they want all the
lettuce the tomatoes and the garlic the
roasted onion that's good let's throw it
back to 2014 for number seven and caught
in his call of the legendary shroud
boost on cash molotovs in set peace out
shroud has let them all pass
who knew counting to three could be so
hype SATA kiss is a man of many talents
csgo caster racecar driver
and surprisingly rap God three two one
go ahead first license if they started
puts it back down and LQK he's gonna get
a forward stance all for them working
the other one goes the inside of the
train out the group back out of the one
on top that I'm not sure who it is but
it's to prove the jobs back down that
was Charles kind of source I would an
isolate forest back inside of the IV
position and IP now table cops see if
that not able flank it back doesn't walk
up the ladders carried in the sits at
the top and you can't climb it site at
the same time he just sits up there cuts
you apart as Kerrigan couldn't do work
again potentially takes down fiber but
that was back in the kitchen being
assist him there's rain against him and
exists where is exist he's still behind
them also pits gonna try and bait them
away be the hot cloth on the fevered
head like a needle they'll lead them and
they'll follow like thread but where it
could exist come back in from behind
he's gonna try and isolate this into a
one-on-one right now and it is not gonna
work out in his favor do I'd take it
back you just get to pray but in the
meantime he did lose his teammate I was
just in the slide is just an top of the
tray not love him would come up with a
ladder and still be just the twelve easy
to work with he has got the butterfly
knife but he has to fly like a butterfly
and sting like a bee he's got the first
one already on the Kerrigan that's all
the way further still need box his lower
device he's got this down hold on what
he actually works it out the clutch from
exist I love it ever heard a man lose
his mind in real-time checkout machine
at number five as his shock only grows
with
every kill of guardians off ace yeah
they come needs rain Oh
Happy's legal ace is widely regarded as
one of the best moments in csgo history
and it's made even better by some lers
iconic call area they aren't rushing
this time around they're taking their
sweet time hoping to catch somebody
Picon envious side head well that's what
happens when you go around the corner
happy with wanting debris is like
sweating bullets and so it's only
fitting that this famous piece of csgo
casting history comes in at number four
have you ever seen a play that made you
question reality
James bard off certainly did at number
three as he watched simple pull off a
1v2
that should have been impossible couple
smokes in the same place
this is the FBI
this is a paid job his reaction upon
seeing the replay he had one file on his
mouth that he had one button zoom is
priceless
EKOS epic 3k against dignitas and
Anders's disbelieving reaction comes in
at number two they want to go all-in Eco
comes in with another killing back to it
you onto that phone so far same thing
gotta move quick right now and going for
it then if yours is already happening a
cry you kidding he's gonna go right they
win the round eco fix up a triple a
cloud nine when it works not only will
the play itself phenomenal but Anders is
call of a royal killer has basically
become a csgo mean which haunts hiko to
this day no I'm not giving you taking
the top spot on the list is seen a kiss
call of snacks is one before clutch
again snobby
not only did he drop the mother of all
dad jokes the Big Apple and snacks is
hungry but his closing reaction is
simply sublime way to be as well on
Guardian and flame he's trying to beat
them out trying to get the middle wall
on Long's as he dances back and forth
between the box
Guardian bye-bye and it's on me
and there you have it those were our
picks for the top 10 best caster calls
and csgo
did we miss any of your favorite calls
let us know in the comment section below
thanks for watching if you want more
great content be sure to hit that
subscribe button